hi derek hi martin
so derek you are developer advocate
specializing in databases right yeah
that's right
great i have a question from a customer
who's building their product on top of
google cloud using serverless products
and they need a relational database for
their application
sure happy to help
[Music]
the customer is building a system using
cloud run and they pick cloud run so
they don't have to provision and
maintain servers
and this reduces the ops work needed to
keep the system running
initially they picked a nosql database
that helped them get their mvp out the
door really quickly that makes sense
they got great feedback from customers
for version one of their system and
they're getting ready for version two
they realize they will need acid
transactions and also aggregations like
sums and averages across thousands of
records from their database and they
can't do that easily in their nosql
database
got it
any particular issues they're trying to
solve with asset transactions
yeah they've been having consistency
issues with the data as more customers
use their app and they're spending a lot
of time fixing those issues
yes okay
do they have any other requirements
well they want a managed database that
scales as they grow and i want to
minimize the ops work needed to keep the
system running
well in that case they should look at
cloud spanner
it's a fully managed relational database
that ensures strong consistency and
great availability
and it has unlimited scalability so it
will easily scale as their needs grow
all right derek let's break that down
you started out saying fully managed
what kind of ops work would they need to
do to keep their spanner running
smoothly
well for starters they don't have to
worry about patching or other typical
server maintenance
they also don't have to manage any
complex architectures for load balancing
or failovers
they don't even have to manage
encryption though spanner has the option
for the customers to manage encryption
keys if they require it
they will have to manage access control
and schedule their own backups
they're also in charge of schema
migrations but spanner manages the
deployment of those changes
schema changes in spanner are online
though so they won't block the app
during the migration
okay and next you said unlimited
scalability uh that's a pretty bold
claim derek
yeah spanner provides consistent
transactions like other relational
databases
and is a horizontally scaling database
similar to nosql databases
so it grows with your data
to give you an idea spanner processes
over 1 billion requests per second at
peak
wow that's a lot
then you said strong consistency how can
a global relational database be strongly
consistent
great question
spanner relies on truetime to provide
commit timestamps to guarantee global
consistency
truetime is an internal google service
that guarantees monotonically increasing
timestamps with microsecond granularity
across all nodes
these timestamps combined with google's
dedicated infrastructure allows spanner
to be strongly consistent at low
latencies
great and finally you said great
availability what does that mean in this
context
spanner comes with an sla guarantee of
up to five nines of availability to
ensure users have access to their data
spanner stores multiple copies of your
data in different zones or regions to
handle maintenance and outages
this is transparent to your application
so your code doesn't need to know where
the replicas are it sounds like spanner
fits the needs of the customer uh could
we take it for a spin yeah
what did you have in mind
my test app is a simple rest api for
managing users i'm thinking i'll swap
out its nosql database with spanner
so to get a feel for how much work it
would take to migrate a real project
we can totally do that
first go to the cloud console click the
hamburger menu and scroll down to the
databases section and click cloud
spanner
then click create instance
okay i did i see a lot of options here
what should i pick if all of your users
are in a single region you'd want a
single region configuration to minimize
latency
if the database will be accessed from
multiple regions or you need five nines
of availability guarantees you'd want
the multi-region configuration
let's use a regional configuration
and i see that the price changes up here
as i change the options
do i need a full node probably not yet
to get started you'd probably want to go
smaller
all right for now i'll set up a dev
environment with 100 processing units
which will come out to 9 cents per hour
or about 65 dollars per month good idea
they can always scale that instance up
later without any downtime all right
i'll click create here
uh now i'll assume my code will need to
change to access banner
yeah i sent you some code before did you
get it uh yep i'm pasting it in now
spanner provides client libraries for
many language including node.js
since our application is node all we
have to do is require the library
instantiate the spanner class and then
provide the instance and database
information
we could tune how session pooling is
handled but the defaults are a great
starting point
accessing the data is done with standard
sql
does my code need to specify which
spanner replica or region to hit
no spanner handles that for you
all you need to specify is the instance
and database
if cloud run is configured with a
service account that can work with
spanner you don't even have to provide
credentials otherwise you can provide
those too
all right
i'm deploying my updated cloud run
service now
uh looks like the api is still working
uh so what kind of loads can it handle
i set up a load test that hits our test
application at roughly three to one
reads to write
which is the observed pattern from
production
i'll start with 32 concurrent users
let's see what happens
uh-huh
looks like a decent amount of operations
per second here
yes
now let's look at the cpu to see how
it's holding up
uh-huh it looks like the load is
crossing the recommended cpu threshold
here uh what do we do
right if it goes much beyond that
threshold you would see request
latencies increase we don't want that
we can just increase the processing
units let's do that now
all right
looks like the cpu is having an easier
time now
and in locust we're able to handle many
more requests per second than before
those extra units really helped pretty
impressive for a globally consistent
relational database with acid
transactions
and nice that you can tweak capacity
while the database is under load
yeah and there are no changes to the
application needed
great the customer will get acid
transactions in a managed database with
spanner they can start small and scale
up without users being impacted thanks
for showing me how to do this derek
you're welcome martin i think spanner
would work well for the next version of
the customer system
yeah i think so thank you everyone for
watching if you have questions for me or
derrick about spanner please enter them
in the comments below also let us know
in the comments if you have suggestions
for other serverless topics we should
bring up on the show
bye for now
[Music]